oh god way to be a foodie killjoy hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at some very commonly demonized food
additives lurking in your food and i'm
gonna break down the truth about whether
or not you should be scared but first a
very quick disclaimer that you can see
on screen or in the description and a
reminder that if you are new here hit
that subscribe button ring that bell and
follow me also over on tiktok and
instagram for more great myth-busting
content all right afo it is time to put
my food scientist hat on today and
address all of those scary instagram
reels and tick tocks that we've all seen
come up in our feeds you know
the ones put out there by the
unregulated influencers with bogus
professional titles like expert food
coach telling you that if you eat
ingredients that you don't recognize
your body doesn't recognize it either
i mean it's a cute little sound bite but
what the [ __ ] does that even mean well
according to said experts all of those
seemingly harmless ingredients lurking
in every corner of your neighborhood
grocery store are causing inflammation
bloating gut disruption cancer leaky gut
headaches fatigue and literally every
other disease
it sounds scariest
and i personally understand this fear i
mean this is precisely the type of
fear-mongering pseudoscience language
that drove me into an eating disorder as
a young adult but here at abby's kitchen
you know we are all about facts not fear
so i think if you'd like we're gonna
start a new series here toxic with abby
sharp
i mean there are a lot of so-called
poisonous ingredients so talk all day on
these but i'm going to start with a few
of the popular ones and break them down
into actual science noble
no fear just pure science with a side of
sass all right first things first
natural flavors now according to the fda
natural flavors derive their aroma and
flavor from naturally occurring plant or
animal sources including fruit meat fish
spices herbs roots leaves buds or bark
these ingredients are then distilled
fermented and manipulated to yield the
desirable flavor now this is in contrast
to artificial flavors which derive their
flavor profile from a synthetic chemical
source but it's important to note that
regardless of the source natural foods
and artificial foods all come from
chemicals and most of the time these
chemical structures are
indistinguishable from each other
regardless of whether they were dry from
a man-made or a natural source so this
to me isn't a concern if someone tells
you otherwise they don't understand food
chemistry now the controversy around
these substances is that natural flavors
are allowed to have things like
stabilizers or preservatives in them aka
artificial ingredients which can help to
you know improve their performance in
food the fda also doesn't require
companies to disclose all of the
ingredients in a flavor blend they can
just say natural flavors so while
research suggests that natural flavors
are safe to consume for the vast
majority of people if you have unique
dietary restrictions or rare allergies
there may be a reason to avoid them so
obviously a vegan may want to avoid
flavors derived from animals and folks
with certain like a fruit allergy or
something may want to avoid flavors
derived from such fruit the good news is
is that if any of the top eight food
allergens were to be used as a natural
ingredient they must declare that on the
packaging so right now sesame currently
is not included in that legislation but
updated labeling regulations are
definitely on the fast track to include
sesame as the ninth allergen to be
listed and thankfully some of the big
companies like hershey's and general
mills have kind of preemptively
an initiative to identify it on the
label anyway so should you be concerned
about the natural flavors in the foods
you eat well when i spoke to aaron at
food science babe who is an actual food
scientist she assured me that food
flavors are actually some of the most
well regulated ingredients in food the
flavor extract manufacturers association
panel aka fema compiles scientific data
on different flavors that are generally
recognized as safe or grass and they
share this information with the fda as
well as international scientific and
regulatory bodies flavor companies don't
necessarily have to disclose the
application of flavor ingredients that
have already passed this review but
anything new or novel would need to go
through this rigorous testing procedure
to demonstrate their safety before it
can be used now if you had a very
specific food allergy that would not be
listed under the top 8 rule then again i
totally understand the desire to avoid
these types of foods but for the general
population these natural flavors are
considered safe and they can make
nutritious foods more palatable and
accessible for more people which we love
and even if we were to be extra extra
skeptical and assume that you know down
the road we were to discover some kind
of concerning element in these foods
remember that the dose always makes the
poison so my personal and professional
opinion is that if you're enjoying ultra
processed foods in moderation and the
words natural flavors aren't the first
and therefore biggest ingredient on
every ingredient list of every food that
you eat the amount consumed is almost
certainly benign and safe for most folks
again assuming that they don't have an
unlisted food allergy drink your damn
lacroix
whatever they're called but i honestly i
say flavored water that you like is
better than plain water that you don't
like next all right we talked flavor
let's talk about color and what i mean
by that is artificial food color or dye
so this one comes up a lot and it's
actually one of the only food related
products that i personally avoid for no
other reason than if i consume a lot of
it it gives me highs but that doesn't
mean that it's universally toxic or bad
now the most common food dyes in the
united states are red 40 yellow five and
yellow six and when i asked food science
babe why some food dyes are banned in
some countries and approved in others
she told me it really comes down to
differences in regulations and
interpretation of data one country's
laws aren't necessarily more protective
than another because often a food may be
approved in one country but banned in
another and vice versa now one of the
big concerns around food dyes is their
potential role in increasing
hyperactivity or adhd in children now a
2004 analysis of 15 studies did find
that artificial food dyes did slightly
increase hyperactivity in children but a
lot of other research suggests that the
effect is genetically determined and not
all children react the same in other
words this is largely inconclusive and
anecdotally is often confounded by the
fact that with artificially colored
foods often comes novel fun experiences
like birthday parties or holidays now
the next question is what about the risk
of cancer well pretty much all of our
research here is done on rats which of
course does not always apply to humans
and even still the only dyes with any
concerning data in this area are blue 2
and red three now while most research
found no adverse effects of blue two on
rodents one study found a statistically
significant increase in brain tumors in
rats given a high dose of blue two
though the researchers warned it wasn't
clear if that was even the result of the
die red three on the other hand is
definitely the most controversial food
dye we've got research on rats here
showing an increase in thyroid tumors so
this resulted in actually a partial band
on the product which was later reversed
when it was concluded that the thyroid
tumors were maybe not directly caused by
the red three regardless if you read
enough food packages today you'll find
that with the exception of some super
old school maraschino cherries candies
and some random popsicles red three has
almost completely been replaced by red
40. so is food dye a huge concern well
like i said before the dose makes the
poison and if maraschino cherries are
making up a significant portion of you
or your children's diet then i would say
we probably have bigger fish to fry next
up everyone's favorite frenemy
monosodium glutamate aka msg now you
probably know of msg as the umami
flavored food additive that's present in
a lot of ultra processed foods and
chinese food takeout but it's really
just a sodium salt of an amino acid
called glutamic acid despite being used
for hundreds of years to enhance
palatability thanks to its umami-like
flavor this ingredient received a bad
reputation back in the 1960s thanks to a
doctor who wrote a letter to the new
england journal of medicine claiming
that he got sick from chinese food
despite no clear association between his
sickness and msg consumption this letter
sparked a cascade of misinformation and
poorly conducted studies on msg which
fueled the fear around this very common
food additive however one review of the
literature found that the majority of
the studies pointing to the harmful
effects of msg
were highly highly flawed and based on
doses that would never be reasonably
consumed by humans or present in food
products so once again the dose makes
the poison now it's also worth pointing
out that a ton of whole foods naturally
contain glutamate and this naturally
occurring glutamate is indistinguishable
to the body from the glutamate in added
msg so vegetables like tomatoes
mushrooms corn broccoli spinach and
green peas as well as cheese and
animal-based protein like chicken beef
salmon and shrimp all contribute to the
approximate 13 grams of glutamate that
adults eat each day even mother's breast
milk which is a food that wellness
culture has long deemed the perfect food
is very high in glutamate in other words
we have been consuming the stuff since
we came out of the womb and likely every
day since having said all of that msg
sensitivity is a real thing but the
research suggests it only affects
roughly one percent of the general
population and that it takes on average
about 3 grams of msg to cause any of
these transient symptoms and the key
here is the word
transient this does not cause permanent
damage since msg can't even cross the
blood-brain barrier otherwise
double-blind placebo multiple challenge
research suggests that the rest of the
population don't actually experience any
symptoms when they don't know they're
consuming msg and since the average msg
enriched food contains only about 0.5
grams of msg i would say that this is a
safe additive that can actually enhance
the palatability of nutritious foods for
the general population and if you're
experiencing excessive symptoms from
takeout and ultra-processed foods again
i think it makes more sense to focus on
maybe adding more fresh meals to your
diet rather than making that one little
additive the scapegoat to blame next
let's talk about high fructose corn
syrup so we know high fructose corn
syrup is a common additive in a wide
range of processed foods but what makes
it unique from let's say table sugar or
honey well chemically speaking not much
while there are super high fructose
versions that can contain up to 90
fructose the most common variety used
high fructose corn syrup 55 has roughly
the same fructose to glucose ratio as
table sugar aka sucrose and it isn't far
off of honey either one of the only
noticeable differences between sucrose
and high fructose corn syrup 55 is that
the syrup is 24 water making it a liquid
while table sugar as we know is dry and
granular chemically the fructose and
glucose in the corn syrup and the honey
are not bound together as they are in
something like sucrose but they actually
all get broken apart in the body anyway
so they end up ultimately looking the
same and as we established high fructose
corn syrup 55 has slightly higher
fructose than sucrose and honey but
despite these very minor differences
research suggests that they all
ultimately have the same metabolic
effects in the body so
what's to blame for the bad rep well
back in the 1980s high fructose corn
syrup consumption increased as it began
to be used more often in food production
as a cheaper alternative to sucrose at
the same time obesity rates in the u.s
began to climb many were quick to point
the finger at high fructose corn syrup
as the culprit however as we know
correlation does not equal causation and
we don't have strong evidence to suggest
that the high fructose corn syrup
specifically is what caused the obesity
epidemic in fact one study tested the
effects of four calorically restricted
diets containing different amounts of
sucrose and high fructose corn syrup and
they found that all of the participants
were able to lose weight even when
consuming the high fructose corn syrup
other research has confirmed that when
comparing equal parts of high fructose
corn syrup to sucrose there have been no
differences observed in fullness insulin
response leptin levels or weight change
sure we could say that something like
honey may have a slight nutritional
advantage to both these other sweeteners
because it contains small amounts of
antioxidants but you would need to
consume a
ton of honey to meet your antioxidant
and micronutrient needs and that my
friends is just as problematic for your
health as consuming an excess of high
fructose corn syrup and actually if we
want to play dirty here folks honey
actually has more calories than table
sugar per tablespoon but anyways most of
us aren't putting high fructose corn
syrup manually on like our oatmeal or on
our berries the way we might use honey
we're ultimately getting it from ultra
processed foods so again my tip here is
to focus on moderating your consumption
of ultra processed foods containing any
kind of sweeteners rather than obsessing
over which specific sweetener it
contains let's not lose sight of the
forest from the trees here folks it's
the dietary pattern not the sweetener
that actually matters and finally let's
round things off with hydrogenated oils
so hydrogenated oils are commonly used
in food manufacturing to increase the
shelf life of processed foods and
enhance their flavor and texture now
it's important to note that there are
two types of hydrogenated oils fully
hydrogenated oils and partially
hydrogenated oils and while they're
similarly used in food manufacturing
they actually result in two different
types of fats unfortunately most food
label experts on instagram don't seem to
understand this i see people call out
hydrogenated oils as trans fats all the
damn time
and this is factually incorrect fully
hydrogenated oils are saturated fats
partially hydrogenated oils are trans
fats and it's the trans fats that are
pretty indisputably regarded as bad for
your health the good news is that trans
fat consumption from processed foods is
not something that you even need to
actively worry about too much here in
north america since canada and the
united states at least have implemented
a trans fat ban and eliminated the use
of partially hydrogenated oils in food
manufacturing hydrogenated saturated
oils on the other hand don't necessarily
carry the same risk to our health which
is why they're still used in food
manufacturing to this day now this is
not to say that saturated fats should be
consumed in excess especially because
the jury is still out on the relative
health risk of saturated fats which i
actually discussed in a lot more detail
in my video right here but while it's
unclear if fat fats are bad good or
neutral it does seem that replacing them
with unsaturated fats is advantageous or
better for our health so where does that
leave us with our consumption of these
hydrogenated oils
say it with me folks
the dose makes the poison
[Music]
music to my ears i really don't see a
huge major health risk with enjoying a
snack food with some hydrogenated oils
in it in the context of an otherwise
balanced day so on that note i hope that
was a good reminder of the general
safety of our food system and that our
focus really should be on the overall
dietary pattern not on singling out
specific nutrients in any one specific
food so if you like this video be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what food additives you
want to see me discuss next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you